la séance est reprise avec la discussion
de la proposition de loi relative à la
maîtrise de l'organisation algorithmique
du travail proposition présentée à part
Monsieur Pascal ça vole des lignes et
Madame Cathy pour ce poli Laurence Cohen
et plusieurs de leurs collègues dans la
discussion générale nous sommes parvenus
à l'intervention de madame Jocelyne
guidez pour le groupe Union centriste
madame guidez vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur mais super collègue
tout d'abord je tiens à remercier
Monsieur Pascal ça vaut Delhi pour son
engagement et notre collègue rapporteur
madame Cathy pour la qualité de son
travail cette option de loi vise à
encadrer le recours aux algorithmes et
la numérisation des relations de travail
il s'agit de renforcer la responsabilité
des employeurs et la protection des
salariés
cette initiative parlementaire s'inscrit
dans le prolongement du rapport
d'information de Pascal sabotelli du 29
septembre 2021 sur l'ubérisation de la
société l'impact des plateformes
numériques sur les métiers et le marché
de l'emploi
selon cette mission d'information étant
à remettre en cause notre modèle social
et économique en imposant en effet à
leur travailleur les pratiques du
management alors qu'il serait nécessaire
de mieux les encadrer
des recommandations sont ainsi formulées
autour de quatre grands axes
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
le développement du dialogue social
l'encadrement du management ainsi que la
transparence et la régulation des
algorithmes des plateformes
antérieurement ce rapport la proposition
de Loire relative au statut des
travailleurs a été rejeté par notre
assemblée en juin 2020 notre collègue
Madame Catherine Fournier souligné alors
que la transformation de la relation
commerciale des travailleurs indépendant
de plateformes en un contrat relevant du
droit du travail centré sur les
plateformes de services étaient trop
restrictives et faisait fui de la
diversité de celle-ci
j'appelle aussi votre attention sur le
travail réalisé par notre collègue Bruno
Retailleau une proposition de loi
déposée en août 2022 relative au
travailleur en station de dépendance
économique vis-à-vis des plateformes
numériques ce texte met l'accent sur le
développement du numérique a donné
naissance à de nouvelles formes
d'organisation du travail l'émergence de
ces dernières a permis l'accès à
l'emploi de personnes qui ont été
parfois éloignées les profils de ces
travailleurs sont variés anciens
chômeurs étudiant actif souhaitant
compléter les revenus d'un emploi
salarié la question de leur protection
est assez abordée par une réflexion sur
leur statut cette option de loi s'appuie
notamment sur les conclusions d'un
rapport de la commission des affaires
sociales en mai 2020 travailleurs de
plateformes au-delà de la question du
statut quelle protection de Madame
Frédéric puissat Monsieur Michel
forestier Madame Catherine Fournier ils
estimaient nécessaires de dépasser ce
débat sur le statut de développer des
droits une couverture sociale
indépendante de ce dernier
le texte de Bruno Retailleau vise en
effet à mettre un œuvre cette
recommandation il ne touche pas au
régime des travailleurs indépendants
mais créer un nouveau type de contrat
sur mesure qui permettra au travailleur
de bénéficier d'une protection sociale
améliorée de mesures de prévention en
matière de santé ainsi que de garanties
sur la transparence du fonctionnement
des algorithmes
ces différents travaux menés au Sénat
témoignent de l'intérêt de ce sujet ces
initiatives parlementaires mettent en
lumière la nécessité de mieux connaître
ce phénomène qui présente tout un
spectre d'activité et de situations
sociales né dans divers secteurs des
mobilités la plateforme méditation c'est
en désormais à l'ensemble de l'économie
elle se traduit par une explosion du
nombre de travailleurs de plateformes 28
millions de personnes dans l'Union
européenne aujourd'hui 43 millions en
2025 selon les estimations cette
nouvelle façon de travailler nécessite
un nouveau regard sur les conséquences
de son amplification et nous impose de
réorganiser le dialogue social dans un
contexte où les discriminations se
développent les travailleurs doivent
bénéficier d'une prospection adéquate
force de constater que ces personnes
souvent précaires isolées et contraintes
de recourir à ses formes d'emploi
cumulent des fragilités faiblesses des
rémunérations protections sociales
incomplète exposition risque
professionnel soumise à un degré élevé
de contrôle elles peuvent ressentir le
sentiment de dépendance à l'égard des
plateformes nous défendons l'idée d'un
travail descend dans le monde en ligne
pour lutter contre les effets
discriminatoires il nous semble
important que la chaîne de
responsabilité soit considérée comme
humaine même si le fonctionnement repose
sur les algorithmes idéalement les
algorithmes doivent être contrôlés
encadrés puisque ils sont utilisés à des
fins de gestion des ressources humaines
d'organisation du travail et de
recrutement notre groupe approuve la
démarche parlementaire consiste à
proposer des améliorations aux
conditions de vie et de travail des
travailleurs de plateforme et diminuer
ainsi leur exposition au risque certes
nous ne pouvons pas voter contre cette
proposition de loi qui vise à améliorer
la transparence de nouveaux modes
d'organisation du travail ainsi qu'à
responsabiliser les employeurs toutefois
chers collègues nous savons qu'au niveau
de l'Union européenne une proposition de
directive sur la reconnaissance d'une
présomption
irréfragable de salariat pour certains
de ces travailleurs est en cours de
négociation il est nécessaire que ces
aboutissent par conséquent il nous
semble prématurés de légiférer sur ce
sujet avant que ce concrétise les
résultats de ces travaux prendre cette
précaution nous paraît logique puisque
notre travail législatif risque d'être
détricoté à l'avenir la prise en
considération de la dimension européenne
constitue une étape importante dans la
construction de solutions concernant
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
ce combat au niveau européen tracera de
nouvelles perspectives pour aborder
cette thématique qui occupera
certainement une place importante dans
les débats sur les droits sociaux des
travailleurs dans les prochaines années
pour l'ensemble de ces arguments le
groupe Union centriste s'abstiendra je
vous remercie de votre attention
merci
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre corbiset pour 5 minutes pour
le groupe RDSE
madame présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
vice-président la commission mes chers
collègues le développement technologique
a longtemps été associé à la notion de
progrès et force est de constater qu'il
a pu être porteur d'avancer réel dans de
nombreux domaines sociaux et économiques
y compris dans le monde du travail
néanmoins il emporte aussi son lot
d'inquiétude et de questionnements dès
lors qu'il percute les droits des
salariés ou interfèrent avec les
conditions de travail ou les process de
recrutement à l'image de la récente
polémique autour du groupe Amazon dont
l'algorithme d'analyse des candidatures
favoriser au final celles des hommes
quel humour s'appelant Amazon
les débats sont d'ailleurs denses
actuellement sur les risques que porte
en soi la progression exponentielle de
l'intelligence artificielle qu'il
s'agisse de son fonctionnement
désincarné ou des abus potentiels sont
des âges et évidemment il est absolument
pas recevable argument qui consiste à
dire que l'outil épar nature innocent et
que ce sont les usages qui peuvent être
détournés il est au contraire de la
responsabilité des concepteurs dans
garantir toutes les sécurités
d'utilisation et de celle du législateur
de fixer le cadre d'exercice de cette
responsabilité c'est précisément ce qui
nous est proposé de faire dans cette
proposition de loi déposée par nos
collègues du groupe CRCE
certes la commission n'a pas adopté le
texte au motif qu'il n'apporterait pas
de garantie supérieure aux salariés et
que des travaux du même ordre sont en
cours au niveau européen et alors
pourquoi attendre l'Europe je crois pour
ma part que lorsqu'il s'agit de la
relation au travail les garanties des
protections des salariés méritent
toujours d'être interrogés et renforcé
d'autant plus dans un contexte où les
discussions européennes semblent pour le
moment assez mal engagés
en mémoire que l'économie des
plateformes concernera d'ici 2025 43
millions de salariés au-delà des
plateformes nombre d'entreprises ont
aujourd'hui pu le virage numérique avec
les objectifs affichés d'améliorer leur
processus d'organisation de simplifier
et d'accélérer leurs moyens d'action ou
encore d'optimiser la gestion du travail
l'informatique peut certes aider mais
n'oublions pas que derrière ces
logiciels et ses algorithmes il y a des
programmateurs qui paramètres leurs
outils en fonction de consignes ou
commandes qu'on leur donne
la décision automatisée d'autant plus
dangereuse qu'elle est prise par nature
de façon opaque et qu'elle peut
reproduire à l'envie des comportements
discriminants avec le risque d'une
standardisation des décisions cela est
d'autant plus inquiétant pour les IA
dites apprenantes capables d'acquérir
une autonomie croissante et dont le
fonctionnement devient complexe à
expliquer voire difficile à maîtriser
partant de là il me semble pertinent
comme le formulaire de la promotion de
loi de clarifier la nature juridique du
recours à l'algorithme comme une
expression du pouvoir de direction et
compte de contrôle de l'employeur
traduisant ainsi l'une des conclusions
de la mission d'information sénatoriale
consacrée à l'ubérisation de la société
même si le automatique est visible une
décision
issue d'un traitement automatisé
n'emporte pas moins des conséquences
pour le salarié et celui-ci doit être en
mesure d'une part de se défendre face à
une décision qui lui est défavorable et
d'autre part de la contester si elle est
l'expression d'une discrimination de ce
point de vue contraint de l'employeur à
apporter la preuve que son algorithme
n'est pas discriminatoire va dans le
beau sens enfin la proposition de loi
s'attaque au sujet des épines des
plateformes et du lieu de subordination
qu'elle impose à ses collaborateurs
présentaient souvent à tort comme
indépendant or le plus souvent ils n'ont
que peu ou pas de maîtrise sur la
gestion de leur mission ni sur la
fixation de leur tarif comme ils ne
peuvent pas véritablement négocier leur
contrat ni constesté les sanctions qui
leur sont appliquées il s'agit ici sans
attendre l'issue des négociations
européennes et avec la préoccupation de
protéger les salariés de ces plateformes
d'intégrer dans notre droit du travail
les jurisprudences uber délivrerous et
élite taxi au delà cette définition
permettra de niveler les responsabilités
entre les employeurs lambda et les
plateformes lesquelles on trouve souvent
exploiter les failles du vide juridique
les concernant pour toutes ces raisons
mes chers collègues notre groupe est
favorable à cette proposition de loi je
vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Serge bebari pour le groupe les
républicains pour cette minute
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le vice-président de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur mes chers collègues un
certain humanisme à la française assez
largement partagé qu'il soit à l'origine
religieuse ou laïque nous a toujours
fait considérer avec inquiétude et
circonspection l'intrusion
d'automatismes dans les relations
interpersonnelles dans le monde du
travail
souvenons-nous de laisser de Georges
Bernanos la France contre les robots qui
dès 1947 formulait une violente critique
de la société industrielle
estimant que le machinisme limiter la
liberté des hommes et perturber jusqu'à
leur mode de pensée
l'actualité concernant les nouvelles
formes d'emploi freelance
micro-entrepreneurs salariés portés et
les modes d'engagement en particulier
sur les plateformes numériques nous
interpelle il s'agit d'accompagner et de
sécuriser le grand mouvement de fond en
faveur de ces nouvelles formes d'emplois
et il apparaît urgent d'examiner
l'ensemble des composantes du travail
indépendant pour révolutionner notre
pack sociale et adapter notre système à
ces transformations
il convient de réinterroger les
dispositifs actuels de protection
sociale dans leur contenu leurs
équilibres et dans leur application il
est vrai que la tentation d'une
ubérisation sociale à partir de
l'organisation algorithmique du travail
a dévoyé ces perspectives cependant
aujourd'hui plus de 28 millions de
personnes dans l'Union européenne
travaille pas intermédiaire de
plateforme de travail numérique en 2025
ce nombre devrait atteindre 43 millions
de personnes c'est un secteur
particulièrement dynamique et innovant
entre 2016 et 2020 les revenus de
l'économie des plateformes ont ainsi été
multipliées presque par 5 passant d'un
montant estimé à 3 milliards d'euros à
environ 14 milliards d'euros
les conditions d'emploi des travailleurs
des plateformes suscitent de nombreuses
inquiétudes partout dans le monde elles
sont liées à leur statut juridique
sont-ils salariés ou contractant
indépendants donc responsable de leur
propre assurance sociale et exercer un
contrôle sur leurs revenus
l'issue de cette controverse leur
protection sociale n'est pas anodine le
débat juridique économique et social est
donc vif en Europe les États ont apporté
des réponses différentes soit par la loi
soit par la jurisprudence par ailleurs
le développement des management de par
algorithme soumet les travailleurs à une
pression constante et un contrôle
intrusif
la première objection à cette
proposition de loi et son caractère
prématuré puisqu'une proposition de
directive européenne est discutée depuis
le 10 décembre 2021 elle vise à garantir
que les personnes travaillant par
intermédiaire de plateforme de travail
numérique se voit accorder le statut
professionnel légal correspondant à leur
modalités de travail réel elle fournit
une liste de contrôles pour déterminer
si la plateforme est un employeur si au
moins deux de ces critères sont remplis
les personnes travaillant par
l'intermédiaire de la plateforme devrait
jouir des droits du travail et des
droits sociaux qui découlent du statut
de salarié après des mois d'intenses
négociation la directive a finalement
été approuvée en plénière du Parlement
européen le 2 février dernier lequel a
supprimé les critères de présomption de
salariat ce qui risque d'entraîner une
incertitude juridique de conduire à des
requalifications massives et au total de
causer des pertes d'emploi
l'Europe doit cependant avancer au même
rythme sous peine sinon de créer des
inégalités de concurrence qui
affaibliront la compétitivité de nos
entreprises la deuxième objection et
qu'elle est réductrice les mutations du
travail ne concerne pas seulement les
plateformes numériques mais de
nombreuses autres branches
professionnelles comme l'ont montré les
travaux de la délégation des entreprises
sur l'évolution des modes de travail et
de management rapportés par nos
collègues Martine Berthet Michel
canevettent et Fabien gay de juillet
2021 le rapport en appelait donc à une
réflexion globale sur la définition
juridique du travail indépendant qui ne
peut se réduire à la seule dimension des
plateformes de mise en relation
il apparaît également que le secteur
public s'empare de cette possibilité en
utilisant des algorithmes pour
l'orientation des jeunes c'est le cas de
la démarche du parcoursup et de France
emploi la troisième objection avec la
traduction par la proposition de loi des
pistes identifiés dans un rapport
d'information le collègue Martine
Berthet Pascal ça vole Delhi sur
l'impact des plateformes numériques sur
les métiers de l'emploi de septembre 21
est inadapté il faut par ailleurs
prendre regarde à ne pas repousser les
micro-entrepreneurs vers le travail non
déclaré avec une réglementation que l'on
souhaite toujours vertueuse mais qui
souvent provoque des effets
contre-productifs pour autant ce
taylorisme numérique est un vrai sujet
que la proposition de loi soulève à
raison il crée une surveillance
constante des travailleurs par une
intelligence artificielle qui les
surveille tout le temps chaque heure
chaque minute chaque seconde
ce management déshumanisant crée un
profond sentiment d'anxiété chez
employés voire de perte de confiance
envers l'employeur pouvant conduire à un
désengagement dans le travail cependant
ce reflexe législatif est-il le bon nous
avons trop tendance en appeler à la
norme pour accompagner l'évolution
économique c'est une réflexion conduite
en ce moment d'ailleurs par nos
collègues Rickman Jean-Pierre Moga et
Gilbert Luc de vinaz il faut simplifier
les normes applicables aux entreprises
la solution est sans doute moins
normative que managériale les employés
acceptent un peu mieux d'être gérés par
une intelligence artificielle si
l'employeur prend le temps de leur
expliquer le pourquoi et le comment de
cette approche managériale car cela
contribue à diminuer la sécurité
professionnelle ou encore la symétrie
d'information et le pouvoir
l'employeur doit adapter son style de
gestion afin que l'ajout d'une
intelligence artificielle ne soit pas
perçue comme une déshumanisation des
ressources humaines mais comme un plus
qui vient améliorer la gestion des
ressources humaines
au bénéfice des travailleurs eux-mêmes à
ce vrai sujet une réponse pertinente
adaptée proportionnée s'impose ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la proposition de
loi laquelle si elle a le mérite
d'attirer notre attention et je me
réjouis du débat qui s'ouvre à cette
occasion ne peut être adoptée je nous
donne en revanche rendez-vous lors de la
transposition de la prochaine directive
européenne en nous gardant bien de
contribuer à la sur transposer ainsi
vous l'aurez compris le groupe les
républicains ne votera pas ce texte je
vous remercie
merci madame Colette mélo vous avez la
parole pour le groupe Les Indépendants
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues depuis sa sortie fin 2022 et
plus encore depuis celle de sa dernière
version chat j'ai pété ne cesse de faire
parler et nourrit autant d'inquiétudes
qui ne fait d'adeptes parmi les craintes
on évoque les risques liés à la
confidentialité des données se relatif à
l'exactitude des informations transmises
par le chatbot et des risques de plagiat
il est aussi régulièrement question des
risques de suppression d'emplois que
cette intelligence artificielle
générative pour écoser à ce titre dans
un rapport publié le 26 mars dernier des
échosnomistes que ce type d'intelligence
artificielle pourrait exposée plus de
300 millions d'emplois à
l'automatisation
mais cette inquiétude de l'articulation
entre le travail et l'évolution
technique et numérique est-elle une
nouveauté pas vraiment la crainte des
évolutions techniques et de leur impact
sur le travail de l'homme existe depuis
longtemps et n'a pas attendu les pontes
de la Silicon Valley en 1589 la reine
Elisabeth première d'Angleterre
interdisait la machine à tricoter les
bas de crainte qu'elles ne prive ces
sujets d'emploi plus récemment dès
l'apparition du vert en France en 2011
des alertes étaient lancées sur le
risque du bérisations de la société et
la nécessité d'adapter notre droit du
travail aux évolutions numériques c'est
donc en permanence que nous devons nous
interroger sur le rapport entre les
évolutions techniques et le travail
c'est ce sur quoi porte la présence
proposition de loi plus exactement
celle-ci nous propose de légiférer sur
l'impact des algorithmes dans la
relation
de travail cette PPL s'inscrit au-delà
du seul cadre des plateformes numériques
l'usage d'algorithmes dans la relation
de travail est aujourd'hui présent bien
plus largement y compris dans des
secteurs qui ne sont pas directement
liés au numérique processus de
recrutement gestion des carrières ou
évaluation des salariés les algorithmes
interviennent de plus en plus dans la
gestion des ressources humaines ce texte
a le mérite d'ouvrir le débat sur cette
nouvelle forme de management qui est le
management algorithmique et sur les
enjeux qu'il soulève si ce type
d'inquiétude n'est pas nouveau ce qui
inquiète davantage c'est le nombre
important et le type d'emploi qui
pourrait être concerné c'est aussi la
rapidité avec laquelle il pourrait
l'être il nous revient d'encadrer leur
usage de sorte qui ne se fasse pas au
détriment des salariés reconnaissons-le
pour les travailleurs comme d'ailleurs
pour les employeurs les algorithmes ont
souvent quelque chose d'abstrait voire
cette PPL pose ainsi des questions tout
à fait légitimes sur l'articulation
entre algorithme et pouvoir de
l'employeur sur les critères et les
paramètres retenus par un algorithme ou
encore sur le statut des travailleurs
des plateformes numériques toutes ces
questions sont pertinentes cependant
nous ne pensons pas que les réponses
soient dans ce texte en effet les
dispositions législatives déjà en
vigueur n'exclut pas du pouvoir de
direction et de contrôle de l'employeur
les décisions prises avec un algorithme
elle ne les exclut pas non plus du
principe de non discrimination est-il
donc nécessaire de légiférer de façon à
préciser que tout ce qui ne serait pas
exclu d'une règle est inclus nous ne le
pensons pas sur la question du statut
des travailleurs de plateformes nous
estimons plus pertinents d'attendre la
directive européenne qui devrait arriver
sous peu il y a une semaine plus d'un
millier de personnalités du monde de la
tech signait une lettre ouverte
suspendre le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle et
s'interroger devrions-nous automatiser
tous les emplois devrions-nous
développer des esprits non-humains qui
risqueraient de nous dépasser en nombre
et à l'intelligence nous rendent
obsolètes et nous remplacer
devrions-nous risquer de perdre le
contrôle de notre civilisation autant de
questions auxquelles les six mois de
suspension demandées par les signataires
ne suffiront sans doute pas à apporter
des réponses les signataires n'en
apportent pas non plus mais ils alertent
au moins sur ce sujet à l'image de cette
PPL il est cependant intéressante dans
des barres et je remercie l'auteur de de
la PPL de nous avoir permis d'y
réfléchir notre groupe votre a contre ce
texte
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Raymond ponce pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues
Marc mcgane ancien dirigeant du Berre
devenu lanceur d'alerte souligna l'heure
de l'audition du 23 mars dernier dans le
cadre de la commission d'enquête
relative aux révélations des
hubert-fight à l'Assemblée nationale
combien de fois ai-je eu à faire à des
gouvernements qui nous accusaient chez
Hubert à raison d'être des hors la loi
mais en privé c'est même gouvernement
nous promettaient de trouver des
solutions rapides et favorables à la
croissance effrénée par exigée par nos
dirigeants et nos investisseurs
investisseurs en quoi ça sert la
démocratie de cacher des rencontres avec
des dirigeants d'entreprise
il poursuit comment se fait-il que le
fer de lance de ceux qui cherchent à
vider de leur sens la directive
européenne ne soit haute que la France
la même France qui a créé la sécurité
sociale en 45 le SMIC en 50 les congés
payés le minimum vieillesse le RSA et la
retraite à 60 ans nous saluons la
proposition de loi de nos collègues du
groupe CRCE qui au-delà des plateformes
numériques dites de mise en relation
adapte une partie de notre droit à
l'avancée de l'organisation
algorithmique du travail dans les
entreprises il nous apparaît
effectivement fondamental et urgent de
définir juridiquement l'algorithme comme
intégration automatisée du pouvoir de
direction d'organisation et de contrôle
de l'employeur employeur seul
responsables l'inciné des critères et
finalités retenus dans le cahier de
charge auprès des programmateurs
informaticiens
le traitement automatisé qui s'ensuit ne
peut masquer et invisibilisé le
concepteur derrière le management
algorithmique oui selon une formule
pertinente de la proposition de loi
l'algorithme est devenu le contremaître
des temps modernes c'est pourquoi
l'employeur doit pouvoir répondre d'un
possible biais de discrimination de
l'algorithme et à l'obligation de son
expliquer et de le corriger et dans le
cas et dans ce cadre le comité social et
économique devrait avoir connaissance
des logiques de fonctionnement des
algorithmes pour exercer pleinement ses
prérogatives enfin concernant le cas
spécifique des plateformes numériques
lorsqu'elles définissent et contrôlent
les caractéristiques essentielles de la
prestation et de la relation de travail
l'article 3 nous invite à intégrer dans
le droit du travail la jurisprudence de
la Cour de cassation en contestant leur
qualité de simples mises en relation
nous appelons dès lors la France à
soutenir enfin au Conseil de l'Union
européenne la directive visant à
améliorer les conditions de travail des
travailleurs des plateformes adopter au
Parlement européen effectivement ce 3
février elle établit une présomption
légale de salariat d'autres pays
européens ont déjà allé légiférer en ce
sens car le récit d'indépendance de
prétendu indépendance des opérateurs de
ces plateformes se révèlent souvent une
fiction déconstruite par la force de
rappel d'une exploitation sans
régulation
faites-vous livrer là où la vie vous
mène propose Hubert via une campagne
commerciale des livraisons réalisées au
détriment des conditions de travail des
coursiers contrôle en temps réel opacité
de la fixation des tarifs dépendances à
l'algorithme dans les fêtes le modèle
économique des plateformes numériques
participent massivement à la
précarisation et à la paupérisation des
travailleurs plus de la moitié des
travailleurs de plateformes de l'Union
européenne gagnent moins que le salaire
horaire net du pays dans lequel il
travaille le journal Le Progrès est
d'autres
journaux régionaux publiait mardi un
dossier sur l'ubérisation titré les
forçats de la livraison
selon la Commission européenne cette
directive permettrait à la France outre
l'amélioration essentielle des revenus
des travailleurs de rentrer entre 328 à
780 millions de recettes annuelles
supplémentaires nous l'avons déjà signé
durant l'examen de la réforme des
retraites voici de vrais alternatives au
financement de la protection sociale
renouant enfin avec le progrès social
aussi le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire votera cette proposition de
loi qui reprend d'ailleurs plusieurs
recommandations de la mission
d'information sénatoriale je vous
remercie
monsieur Ludovic est vous avez la parole
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique progressiste indépendant
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission chers
collègues
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
cet après-midi en temps encadré
d'avantage la numérisation des relations
de travail en définissant juridiquement
l'algorithme en renforçant notamment
également les prérogatives d'information
et de contrôle des comités sociaux et
économiques et en légiférant sur le cas
particulier des plateformes de mise en
relation en effet en 2021 nous avons
mené une mission d'information dont
j'avais été Elvis Président je salue le
travail du Président parce qu'elle Savoy
Delhi qui était avec nous sur ce sujet
portant notamment sur l'impact des
plateformes numériques et sur les
métiers et l'emploi que cela génère nous
avons formulé diverses recommandations
autour de quatre grands axes avec
notamment l'amélioration des conditions
de travail le développement du dialogue
social l'encadrement du management
algorithmique ainsi que la transparence
et la régulation des algorithmes des
plateformes
ainsi madame la rapporteur si nous
soutenons l'objectif de votre texte qui
est bien l'amélioration de la protection
des salariés dans le cadre d'une
relation algorithmique du travail nous
sommes cependant nous ne sommes
cependant pas totalement en adéquation
avec les moyens invoqués en effet
concernant l'article premier nous ne
pensons pas que le dispositif proposé
apporte des garanties supplémentaires au
travailleur car l'employeur est déjà
responsable de ces décisions même
lorsqu'il a recours à divers moyens
technologiques nous serions plutôt
favorables à un dispositif qui
permettrait d'améliorer l'information
des travailleurs sur ces plateformes qui
faciliterait leur accès aux données
générées par leur activité et qui
contribuerait à les supprimer
automatiquement à intervalles réguliers
de l'historique de leur donner
la garantie de l'intelligibilité des
algorithmes pour les travailleurs et
bien la première étape indispensable
pour faire du contenu de l'algorithme un
véritable objet de négociation et pour
permettre que ces problématiques
intègrent le dialogue social
concernant l'article 2 si nous sommes
favorables à une lutte plus accrue
contre les discriminations au travail
qui peuvent être aggravés par
l'utilisation des algorithmes nous
pensons cependant que le dispositif
proposé est déjà satisfait par le droit
en vigueur il nous faut également
rappeler que la procédure relative au
contentieux des discriminations au
travail peut déjà s'appliquer au recours
comme l'a dit Madame la Ministre ce
matin contre les décisions des
employeurs prises à l'aide d'outil
technologique au fil des auditions que
nous avons menées durant cette mission
d'information nous avons acquis la
conviction canalgorithme n'était pas
seulement une suite d'opération
permettant de traiter des volumes
importants de chaîne de données mais bel
et bien une chaîne de responsabilité
humaine le long de laquelle il demeure
possible d'intervenir à chaque moment de
son utilisation
cela peut être effectué en rappelant la
possibilité pour les salariés par
exemple d'utiliser le statut de lanceur
d'alerte si votre article numéro 3
soulève le sujet très attendu de la
définition et de la qualification des
travailleurs de plateforme nous pensons
cependant que nos travaux gagneraient à
être orientés sur l'amélioration
concrète des protections dont
bénéficient ces travailleurs je ne vous
apprends rien des négociations sont en
cours à ce moment au moment où je vous
parle au Conseil de l'Union européenne
au sujet de la directive liée à la
présomption légale de salariat cela a
été présenté en décembre 2021 par la
Commission européenne cette
requalification que nous soutenons
permettra un réel renforcement des
droits des travailleurs des plateformes
le développement des plateformes
numériques a considérablement transformé
notre rapport au travail ainsi que notre
modèle social et économique le travail
est bien le secteur qui a subi l'une des
évolutions les plus considérables de
notre société ces dernières années
nécessitant une adaptation très forte de
la part des travailleurs
la généralisation du télétravail induite
par la crise sanitaire et plus récemment
les débats animés sur le sujet des
retraites ont démontré toute
l'importance et les inquiétudes des
Français à ce sujet ainsi si nous
soutenons certains des constats
effectués par cette proposition de loi
et je tiens ici à saluer tout le travail
effectué notre groupe RDPI ne votre a
pas en faveur de ce texte toutefois nous
nous positionnons pour engager une
réflexion d'ensemble sur le sujet du
travail et des valeurs qu'il accompagne
pour aboutir infinie à l'élaboration des
textes législatif je vous remercie
Madame Corinne Ferret vous avez la
parole pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour débattre de la
proposition de loi relative à la
maîtrise de l'organisation algorithmique
du travail le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain accueille très
positivement ce texte tant qu'il est en
phase avec l'actualité chaque jour
démontre que la plateforme la
plateformeisation pardon du travail
n'est ni plus ni moins qu'un cheval de
Troie contre notre modèle social avec au
coeur de sa matrice l'opacité de la
boîte noire que l'algorithme nous avons
toujours affirmé n'être en rien opposé
au développement de l'économie numérique
et aux plateformes collaboratives qui
rendent de nombreux services à nos
concitoyens mais nous avons souhaité
faire continuellement la distinction
entre ces interfaces et les plateformes
numériques de travail qui dérégulent le
marché du travail et de nombreux
secteurs d'activité formulé aussi des
propositions afin de réguler cette
plateformeisation de l'économie c'est
ainsi que notre collègue Monique Lubin
portait dès 2019 une proposition de loi
visant à rétablir les droits sociaux des
travailleurs numériques
en France plusieurs milliers de femmes
et d'hommes ont été séduits par les
promesses de plateformes qui proposent
une organisation libre du temps du
travail sans contrainte hiérarchique en
pratique à cette illusion de liberté se
substitue fréquemment une réalité bien
plus brutale les travailleurs se
retrouvent très rapidement pieds liés
face aux exigences des plateformes du
jour au lendemain certains d'entre eux
voire leur compte suspendu souvent sans
aucune justification c'est d'autant plus
dur qu'ils sont privés de nombreux
droits sociaux du fait du statut fictif
de travailleurs indépendant nul ne peut
plus nier que la dématérialisation des
entreprises à laquelle nous assistons
avec l'intelligence artificielle et plus
largement le numérique bouleverse toutes
les relations de travail de plus en plus
travailleurs seront gérés par un
algorithme qui attribuera des tâches les
rémunèrent organisera leur travail les
évalueront et même les sanctionnera
l'enjeu se trouve désormais dans la
maîtrise de ces algorithmes il est de
notre responsabilité de garder la main
mise sur les innovations technologiques
avant de nous faire dépasser par
celle-ci en et contrôler tel devrait
être nos maîtres mots si le rôle de
simple intermédiaire de mise en relation
est souvent avancée par les plateformes
elles-mêmes pour décrire le
fonctionnement des algorithmes personne
ne peut plus lier que le management
algorithmique contribue au contraire à
déterminer des conditions de travail et
de rémunération des travailleurs bien
au-delà d'une simple mise en relation
entre offre et demande les algorithmes
de tarification les mécanismes
d'incitation et les systèmes de notation
ont des effets directs sur le
comportement des travailleurs des
plateformes modifiant leur organisation
et leur temps de travail ne leur
permettant pas d'avoir de la visibilité
sur le revenu ni sur leurs projets
professionnels un algorithme n'est pas
seulement une suite d'opérations
permettant de traiter des volumes
importants de données mais bien une
chaîne de responsabilité humaine le long
de laquelle il demeure possible
d'intervenir à chaque étape de sa
conception et de son utilisation se
faisant nous faisons nous sommes bien
évidemment favorables à la proposition
de loin du groupe CRCE qui reprend
d'ailleurs plusieurs propositions du
rapport de la mission d'information du
Sénat sur le bérialisation de la société
que nous avions approuvé en plus de
participer activement à cette mission
notre groupe avait rédigé une
contribution notamment pour insister sur
la légitime question du statut des
travailleurs des plateformes oui nous
devons inscrire dans la loi que les
décisions des employeurs prises à l'aide
de moyens technologiques sont des
décisions relevant de leur pouvoir de
direction oui il importe en cas de
litige portant sur une discrimination au
travail que ce soit à l'employeur
d'apporter la preuve que les outils qui
l'utilisent ne sont pas source de
discrimination notre collègue Olivier
Jacquin dans sa PPL visant à contrôler
la place de l'algorithme dans les
relations contractuelles avaient
d'ailleurs déjà émis ce souhait et oui
enfin il convient de conforter le
mouvement jurisprudentiel actuel en
faveur de la requalification de certains
travailleurs de plateformes ceci en
soulignant bien la distinction réelle
entre d'une part les véritables
opérateurs de mise en relation et
d'autre part les plateformes d'emploi
qui exercent un contrôle juridique et
économique sur les éléments essentiels
de la relation qui les lit avec les
travailleurs
il est grand temps d'avancer sur ces
sujets l'intelligence artificielle est
utilisée dans des outils qui visent à
éclaircir la prise de décision ou pour
surveiller les employés cela crée une
asymétrie de pouvoir et d'information
l'algorithme déformant l'ensemble des
conditions de travail nous avons le
devoir aujourd'hui d'agir pour y
remédier je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
Fabien gay vous aimez la parole pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier mon collègue Pascal
ça vole Delhi pour la présentation la
proposition de loi visant à mettre en
oeuvre une maîtrise de l'organisation
algorithmique du travail
celle-ci s'inscrit dans la continuité de
son tour de France et de son travail
pour la création d'un véritable statut
des travailleurs
des plateformes numériques je remercie
également ma collègue Katia poursuppoli
pour la présentation de son rapport et
pour les auditions qu'elle a conduite et
qui ont permis d'enrichir le travail de
Pascal cette réflexion sur le travail
dans notre société est essentielle
plutôt que de voter pour la retraite à
64 ans et de voler les deux plus belles
années de vie à la retraite des
travailleurs et des travailleurs le
gouvernement et la droit de sénatoriale
aurait été plus inspiré d'avoir un débat
sur le partage des richesses et le sens
du travail nous ne pouvons plus en faire
l'économie
le travail connaît des mutations avec la
généralisation de l'information et la
robotisation amorcé dans les années 1980
et maintenant avec une étape
supplémentaire l'intelligence
artificielle et les algorithmes ces
algorithmes qui dictent les contenus de
nos téléphones nos articles de presse
nos pensées nos vies en nous orientant
seulement vers ce que nous aimons il
nous prive de découverte et donc de
l'inconnu mais il modifie aussi notre
rapport au travail et notre vie en
société nous leur sommes donc
subordonnés en tant qu'être humain
citoyenne et citoyen et travailleurs et
travailleuses il y urgent d'encadrer
l'intelligence artificielle et les
algorithmes même Elon Musk qui est
fondamentalement opposé aux droits
sociaux et syndicaux a réclamé avec une
centaine d'experts mondiaux une pause de
6 mois dans la recherche sur les
intelligences artificielles c'est bien
un comble car elle pose un problème
de protection des données de
dérégulation du marché de l'emploi et de
circulation de fausses informations sous
couvert de neutralité d'équité ces
algorithmes sont en réalité des aides à
la décision de l'employeur
demeure le seul donneur d'ordre et donc
ils sont subjectifs il s'agit d'un
nouvel outil de contrôle des
travailleurs des travailleurs de
management mais aussi de discrimination
et même parfois de répression syndicale
ce n'est plus le patron qui vous
licencie c'est l'algorithme qui vous
suspend c'est pourquoi nous proposons de
modifier le code du travail pour que les
décisions prises à l'aide de moyens
technologiques relèvent du pouvoir de
direction de l'employeur qui lui
programme la machine à son avantage car
la relation travaille est certes moins
directe avec l'employé mais elle reste
contractuelle et accroît la domination
l'employeur en faisant peser de
nouvelles contraintes sur les salariés
en étant même en étant maître de sa
programmation et en organisant l'opacité
il reste le décideur unique et donc il y
a bien un lien de subordination ces
algorithmes incitent à davantage de
rendement en notant les travailleurs les
travailleurs et les pouces a toujours
plus de productivité il est d'ailleurs
urgent de leur garantir un droit à la
déconnexion car le contremaître
numérique lui ne prend jamais de pause
et surtout l'algorithme est froid avec
lui plus de débats plus d'associations
du salarié aux prises de décision ou
même de discussions sur le sens du
travail l'intelligence artificielle et
l'algorithme c'est travaillent et
tais-toi ne pas légiférer c'est refuser
d'équilibrer la relation entre les
employeurs et les travailleurs c'est
donc laissé ces salariés en dehors du
champ du code du travail et refusé de
les protéger face à un système qui
s'étendra peut-être demain à tous les
champs de salariat
qui dit algorithme dit souvent salarié
déguisé reconverti en auto-entrepreneur
sans droit ni salaire mais avec une
rémunération à la tâche et la contrainte
de faire 60 heures par semaine pour s'en
sortir la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat estimée qu'il était
prématuré de légiférer avant
l'aboutissement des travaux européens
pourtant le Sénat français devrait faire
avancer la législation notre proposition
de loi porte cette ambition elle prend
acte de la résolution adoptée par la
Confédération européenne des syndicats
du 6 décembre dernier celle-ci a établi
la nécessité pour les syndicats les
représentants des travailleurs de
bénéficier d'une expertise externe pour
évaluer l'impact des algorithmes sur les
conditions de travail oui il faut de la
transparence et de l'expertise pour
rééquilibrer la relation au travail des
plateformes numériques et nous proposons
de lever la zone d'ombre concernant le
véritable statut des travailleurs et
travailleuses dès lors que les
plateformes en cas juridiquement
économiquement l'activité des
travailleurs ils ne peuvent pas être
considérés comme des travailleurs
indépendants ils doivent être reconnus
comme ce qu'ils sont à savoir des
salariés dans un rapport de
subordination avec les plateformes face
aux entreprises qui ne respectent ni
leur obligation fiscale ni leur
obligation administrative la loi doit
imposer le respect de leur obligation
sociale et donc nous voterons cette
proposition de loi
Olivier Jacquin vous avez la parole pour
4 minutes pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur chers collègues je
veux à mon tour remercier notre collègue
Pascal symbole du lit et le groupe
communiste de nous permettre une
nouvelle fois de débattre de l'impact du
numérique sur le travail des nouvelles
formes de travail de la
plateformeisation et de ce qu'on appelle
plus communément l'ubérisation chers
collègues c'est le quatrième texte sur
lequel sur le sujet que nous étudions
depuis quatre ans après déjà deux
missions d'information et je ne compte
pas le nombre de textes déposés pour
continuer d'alimenter nos réflexions à
croire que l'on parle davantage du
travail grâce aux initiatives
parlementaires que dans les projets de
loi du gouvernement la question au fond
central qui est devant nous est simple
comment s'assurer que le progrès
technologique permettent l'émancipation
des travailleurs et non leur
assouvissement via un contremaître de
point zéro
Corinne Ferret a eu l'extrême
gentillesse de citer ma proposition de
loi de 2021 refusé ici dans laquelle
nous mettons déjà en avant la nécessité
de contrôle et de transparence des
algorithmes le texte qui nous est
présenté aujourd'hui continue d'avancer
dans la bonne direction et je m'étonne
que la majorité sénatoriale continue de
se cacher sur ce sujet majeur après le
revirement opéré l'année dernière lors
des débats sur les ordonnances dites
Mettling en 2019 la commission des
affaires sociales affirmée dans un
rapport être opposé au tiers statut mais
en 2021 vous avez donné un blanc saint
au gouvernement dont l'intention tout
comme celle de leur rapporteur de
l'Assemblée nationale était limpide je
cite réduire le faisceau d'indices
susceptibles de révéler l'existence d'un
lien de subordination de telle sorte que
le risque de qualification soit aussi
réduit que possible je ne fais que vous
citez madame la ministre puisque vous
étiez la rapporteur sur ce texte vous
oubliez pourtant que de ces travailleurs
sont des indépendants fictifs comme les
a qualifiés la Cour de cassation grâce à
l'excellent rapport de Cathy a poursu
politique que je salue j'apprends que
notre collègue Frédéric puisse a évoqué
en commission une position plus nuancée
portée par la majorité sénatoriale sans
pour autant nous en dire davantage et
sans poser d'amendement à ce texte j'ai
peine à comprendre si je peux rejoindre
notre collègue Pascal grenier sur le
fait qu'il faille s'assurer que le texte
que nous votons soit en conformité avec
la directive de Nicolas Schmitt en cours
de discussion au niveau européen et que
vous n'avez même pas cité madame la
ministre je ne peux dès lors que vous
appeler toutes et tous à voter la
proposition de résolution européenne que
j'ai déposé hier avec mes collègues
Monique lumin et Laurent sarribe nous y
appelons le gouvernement à soutenir ses
directives qui garantit de véritables
droits aux travailleurs des plateformes
je rappelle que cette directive reprend
beaucoup des propositions que le groupe
socialiste défend ici depuis des années
et notamment dans ma PPL de 2021 la
présomption de salariat l'inversion la
charge de la preuve en matière de
requalification et la transparence des
algorithmes cette directive c'est
directives reprend par ailleurs une idée
que je mets au débat depuis plusieurs
années une adaptation du devoir de
vigilance des multinationales à
l'ubérisation pour garantir aux
travailleurs un ultime filet de sécurité
en effet l'article 8 de la directive
institut qu'ils pourront exiger des
explications sur les décisions
algorithmiques les impactants avec
obligation pour la plateforme de
répondre par écrit sous une semaine un
article qui est donc en parfaite
concordance avec la présente proposition
de loi mais surtout chers collègues en
votant ce texte nous disons au
gouvernement qu'il fait fausse route
qu'il doit arrêter de bloquer une
directive proposant un cadre de
régulation des algorithmes pour la
protection des travailleurs de
plateformes et espérer son adoption sous
la présidence espagnole de l'Union
européenne dès lors avec mon groupe nous
vous appelons malgré les réserves qui
ont pu être émises par les uns ou les
autres à voter ce texte je vous remercie
merci je l'addition générale est close
la commission n'ayant pas élaboré de
texte nous passons à l'édition des
articles de la proposition initiale je
mets donc on voit l'article premier qui
est pour
j'en profite parce que je veux peser sur
le vote donc je vais essayer de vous
convaincre de tous voter l'article 1 et
notamment pendant ce qui a dit Madame la
Ministre parce que Madame l'ami j'en
profite mais franchement tout à l'heure
je vous ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention vous avez dit que tous les
dispositifs étaient bons en termes de
dialogue social et de lutte contre le
salariat déguisé et cet article qui
définit l'algorithme au plan juridique
comme pouvoir direction et de contrôle
mais je vais vous dire Madame la
Ministre franchement allez voir les
livreurs allez voir les femmes qui font
le ménage allez voir je vais vous en
citer moi des professions qui sont
détournées plateforme numérique de
travail vous savez ce qu'ils disent
mon patron c'est un algorithme mon
patron c'est un algorithme c'est pas le
patron qui c'est pas la notion de patron
qui était jugé c'est une façon que ça
soit désincarné déshumanisé voilà donc
je vais vous dire ça fait pas ça fait
pas et quand vous nous dites il y a le
dialogue social il a été il est au
rendez-vous mais franchement aller voir
les prud'hommes allez voir les juges aux
prud'hommes ce qu'ils disent la
difficulté qu'ils ont parce que
maintenant il y a de plus en plus de
contentieux et vous verrez madame la
ministre que les leviers de négociation
soyez à la place de ces hommes et ces
femmes comment vous défendez vos
intérêts particuliers et la négociation
collective qu'en face vous avez un outil
totalement dématérialisé et des
humanisés donc voilà si on veut être
levier béquille je pense ça serait bien
de voter déjà au moins l'article 1 merci
à mes collègues de l'air de faire un
petit geste
puisque vous m'y invitez je vais donc le
mettre au revoir cet article 1
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté
monsieur
ouzoulliath voulait paroles sont
l'article 2 du coup
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mais mes chers collègues je
voudrais revenir sur la parabole
historique de la relation entre la
technologie et le travail qui me semble
tout à fait intéressante cher collègues
vous auriez pu aussi citer beaucoup plus
loin Pline l'Ancien qui rapporte que
l'empereur Tibère avait mis à mort un
ouvrier verrier qui lui proposait le
verre incassable parce que ça m'était en
danger toute la profession des verriers
il y a aussi la révolte des canaux en
1819 contre les machines à attendre les
draps mais en l'occurrence il ne s'agit
pas du tout de cela jusqu'à présent il y
avait une relation sociale du travail
entre des employeurs et des salariés là
il y a une nouvelle chose qui arrive qui
est la plateforme considérée comme un
monstre noir
neutre complètement technique qui
fonctionne avec des algorithmes et qui
donne l'illusion que son travail ne
serait que de mettre en relation des
clients et des auto-entrepreneurs ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre chers
collègues c'est que dans cette
technique algorithmique ce qu'il y a
c'est la nogation la négation totale de
la relation sociale du travail et une
fine et la négation de ce qui est
l'entreprise avec des plateformes vous
en avez plus d'entreprises et vous
n'avez plus aussi d'entrepreneurs donc
je pense que ce qui est en jeu et tout à
fait fondamental parce que ça touche à
beaucoup de points qui concernent notre
société je pense aussi à la difficulté
que nous avons pour légiférer contre les
gafams et contre leur incapacité à
pouvoir réglementer les propos haineux
en ligne il s'agit du même problème on
nous on nous laisse à croire que les
plateformes seraient des outils
techniques complètement neutres ce que
nous voulons nous c'est remettre du
social derrière ça nous sommes tout à
fait contre l'irresponsabilité sociale
organisée par les algorithmes merci
madame la Présidente
merci je vais donc mettre au voile
l'article 2 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
également adopté je vais maintenant
mettre au voile article 3 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
également adopté et mes chers collègues
sur l'ensemble du texte j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe les républicains
il y a une demande de scrutin public par
le groupe les républicains
mais monsieur savoldenis je vous donne
la parole avant le scrutin avant le vote
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mais mes chers collègues vous
pourrez réagir mes propos parce que je
vais essayer d'interpréter la demande de
scrutin public
parce que pourquoi il y a ce côté un
public
parce que à travers la question de
l'algorithme
il y a des questions qui ont été
évoquées d'ailleurs par plusieurs de mes
collègues
de tous les bancs
c'est que derrière il y a la question du
temps de travail
et ouais il y a la question de comment
définir un salaire comment on définit la
valeur ajoutée
il y a ces questions là qui sont
derrière
et ces questions là elles sont je
m'excuse mais je vous le dis et
d'ailleurs elles sont pas que de gauche
il y a plein de gens en ce moment qui se
mobilisent par rapport aux retraites
parce qu'ils sont préoccupés aussi par
leur niveau de retraite mais aussi leur
niveau salarial leurs conditions de
travail le sens de leur travail etc
donc là je dis ça parce que des fois on
nous dit notamment au gouvernement qui
aurait il y aura
une confusion un brouillard sur le
clivage gauche-droite on voit bien qu'à
la fin sur cette question là il y a
réellement un clivage gauche droite mais
la droite n'est pas quelque chose due
forme et monolithique il y a des droites
en France et comme il y a des gauches
sauf que là les gauches sont rassemblés
unis et là les droites n'ont pas tout à
fait la même approche du sujet merci
donc nous allons procéder au scrutin
et le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc clos
alors vote en 319 exprimé 262 pour 104
contre 158 de Sénat n'a pas adopté
et nous allons donc
monsieur le Président vous voulez la
parole je vous la donne
le président juste de mots donc le
scrutin qui avons refaite la position de
la Commission mais je vais quand même
remercier notre collègue ça voldemi
d'avoir apporté ce sujet là même si on
peut évoquer toute la qualité du débat
dans l'hémicycle ça a permis quand même
que dans chaque groupe politique on se
pose un certain nombre de questions que
vous avez l'air très bien évoqué au
moment de votre dernière intervention
sur les enjeux de la condition de
travail sur les enjeux du temps de
travail également sur la responsabilité
des employeurs dans cette situation là
et notamment ça appelle beaucoup des
lieux locaux il y a les parlementaires
mais aussi les locaux des élocaux qui
vivent au quotidien cette situation là
donc merci d'avoir apporté ce débat dans
les différents groupes merci d'avoir
apporté le débat la commission d'infa
sociale c'est après midi c'était plus
une litanie de d'intervention mais la
Commission internationale nous avons
vraiment évoqué le sujet et je voudrais
remercier le travail et le rapporteur
qui a su au-delà de reprendre à cet
homme d'arguments qu'elle suit en tout
cas lever le débat en commission à faire
social en posant un certain nombre de
questions pour faire réagir notamment
ceux qui travaillent sur les conditions
et des conditions de travail de
l'ensemble des salariés voilà donc au
delà de tout ça je pense que c'est un
sujet qui sera de nouveau d'actualité
dans cette hémicycle parce qu'on voit
qu'il y a encore beaucoup
d'interrogations beaucoup de questions
on va tant beaucoup de la directive
européenne mais je crois que ça se fait
pas tout et donc en tous les cas je
voulais en tous les je vous donne donner
rendez-vous parce que nous aurons
certainement avec le gouvernement
l'occasion de revenir sur ce sujet
très bien je vous remercie je vais donc
suspendre la séance
manuel ministre pardon
mesdames merci madame la Présidente très
brièvement mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais effectivement à
mon tour vous remercier pour la qualité
des débats je sais qu'effectivement
beaucoup d'entre vous sont pleinement
impliqués depuis de longues années
maintenant avec cette volonté de
travailler autour des conditions de
travail plus largement pour l'ensemble
des travailleurs en France mais
évidemment de s'adapter aux évolutions
sociétales et de ce que vient ce que
vienne percuter finalement ces nouvelles
formes de travail ces nouvelles
modalités également de pilotage des
activités si je puis dire c'est évident
que cette question elle a toute sa place
dans le débat public elle a d'ailleurs
je tiens à le redire eu toute sa place
dans le cadre des Assises du travail je
vous propose que nous puissions
travailler sur le compte-rendu aussi des
Assises du travail et puis avancer au
regard des évolutions des textes
européens mais également des
concertations nationale autour de ces
enjeux pour que nous puissions
évidemment nous assurer que notre socle
de droit de jurisprudence et puis aussi
toute notre
dialogue paritaire en France puisse
accompagner ses évolutions sociétales
donc merci à vous toutes et tous pour la
qualité de ces débats et évidemment
restons j'ai envie de dire dans dans
l'attention des évolutions des
différentes textes les législatifs qui
arrivent aux différents niveaux et des
différentes évolutions qu'on pourra
porter ensemble
je vous remercie il n'y a pas d'autres
demandes d'intervention dans ce cas je
vais lever la séance pour 10 minutes
elles sont en reprise à 16h la séance
est suspendue
[Musique]